so yeah there's all kinds of beings that
exist out there and uh and some
absolutely inter interface with Humanity
interface with our government you know
for instance I knew I know a guy he's
passed over now he worked with many
presidents of the United States his
mother was a human being his father was
not he did so much to keep people safe
on this planet and sometimes when things
were happening on the planet that were
very terrible or about to be terrible
him and his people had to intervene he
would call us together one two three
o'clock in the morning we'd have to go
into meditation in prayer people are
seeing sightings all over these crafts
that can stop and go stop and go up and
down and for years I have a a friend
that was um in this service and he would
see they would see different crafts
hovering all the time they were told you
can't tell anybody what you see